[Music]
scp-682 had escaped containment and it
was all hands on deck at the scp
foundation to try and stop the
creature's rampage all unarmed personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip them apart as the security
team bravely fought to incapacitate the
hard-to-destroy reptile long enough to
return him to his acid tank 682 was on
an all-out offensive stomping through
the scp's item gallery and spewing acid
at anyone who came within range people
items and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked it
was an absolute bloodbath and you'd have
to be insane to try and fight back
against it however one being remained
unfazed by the chaos and stood proud in
the face of the omnicidal monster it was
another scp one who had broken free from
its glass display case in the commotion
who does disturb the prime minister
sinister it said in a high tinny voice i
shall rip your eyes from their sockets
and force you to eat them
scp-682 stopped to see who had
threatened him it was almost laughable
that this thing had dared to make such a
violent threat because there was no way
that this little thing would be able to
stand up to the unkillable 682 but its
size didn't stop it from trying to pick
a fight all the same the scp was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton its head was made
of an upside-down voltmeter giving it
the appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it took a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp 682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize you are weak pathetic
said 682 raising his claw to get a
better look at the annoying little robot
it responded lies in slander the mayor
of mayhem is the most powerful being in
existence before promptly losing its
grip on 682's claw and falling to the
floor now 682 was really getting tired
of this thing he prepared to swipe at it
again this time using his full strength
which would certainly smash the robot to
pieces but luckily for the robot its
pestering had distracted 682 just long
enough for the foundation security to
sneak up on him before 682 had a chance
to smash the robot the foundation fired
on him with a volley of rockets reducing
him to a misshapen lump the security
team collected up 682's remains ready to
put them back into a backup acid tank
but the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact the robot was
running around underfoot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 682
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by foundation personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies common sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in scp
gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top-heavy design pesterbot falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pastorbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in english french and latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682 and the cockiness it expressed
in the moment wasn't an aberration this
scp really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a
fight with anyone and anything that
moves this even includes its own
reflection and as a result the glass of
its container must be made as
non-reflective as possible to prevent
the robot from damaging the case or
itself in attempts to fight its mirror
self though its most commonly used
nickname in the foundation is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by a variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robo-lord the destructor and darth
claw killflex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
garglemost to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified as safe and is treated by
most scp foundation employees as a
humorous oddity rather than a legitimate
threat many tests have been done on
pesterbot and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable
of inflicting any damage to its
opponents in fact pesterbot is more a
danger to itself than to anything around
it both because it's incredibly clumsy
and awkward and because it frequently
picks fights with other scps who are far
more powerful than it one such scenario
that could have gone far worse for
pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with scp-846
also known as robodude one of the many
dr wondertainment products currently
kept in foundation containment robodude
is an ordinary looking toy robot that
upon request can produce up to 350 robo
accessories that function as real
weapons robodude can deploy everything
from a rocket launcher to a flamethrower
to a gun that shoots out an unknown
species of insect that can chew through
wood however robodude seems to not be
sentient and is unable to use these
weapons unless asked to that ultimately
worked out in the favor of pesterbot
during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robodudes searching for a robo-pal to
play with came upon pesterbot who
immediately started spouting its usual
over-dramatic threats i am the crush
master doomed to all i survey pesterbot
said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that i might know
whose destruction i shall sow robo-dude
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pesterbot if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to trash talk
robodude until robodude decided the best
way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its robo dance mode
pesterbot accepted the challenge saying
activate all that you wish but your fate
is sealed the killotron cannot be
defeated i shall render you unto dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in the dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped
pesterbot failed miserably at while
robodude was a competent dancer
pesterbot could only gyrate pathetically
before it fell over and rolled around
the ground hopelessly out of time to the
music coming from robodude's speakers
the song ended and robbo dude declared
robo dance is complete robo-pow
pesterbot was unable to accept its
failure and replied ha pathetic one you
have been schooled in the art of the
dance by none other than the meccano
basher scourge of a thousand worlds
kneel before me before i end your
worthless existence robodude unimpressed
with pesterbot's poor sportsmanship
deployed its hydrogen cannon which it
was programmed to do whenever it
detected a sore loser fortunately for
pesterbot hydrogen cannon was just the
name for robodude's water pistol while
pesterbot will attempt to fight anything
that moves the truth is this robot will
attack virtually anything it perceives
as being even slightly alive this is
perhaps best illustrated by one of the
tests of pesterbot's abilities that
involve putting a small speaker at the
base of a potted house plant and
speaking through it from another room
the plant was placed across from
pesterbot in the testing chamber and the
interaction was monitored by researchers
from outside researcher davey spoke
through the speaker in the plant pot he
asked pesterbot if he could hear him and
it answered who dares all souls will
burn you will feel the shock sting of my
wrath identify yourself so that i may
sing damnation upon you as you die the
robot began approaching the plant davies
speaking as the plant identified himself
i'm a split leaf philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy
leaves at this point he had to try very
hard not to laugh at the absurdity of
this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to
three feet long pesterbot used its
wrench to try and wrestle with the
leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage in
rage by its failure it said your mockery
spells your dome i have arrived you will
be crushed betwixt my digits pesterbot
then fell over and was unable to write
itself it struggled and spent six
minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant which
did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken
time to compose themselves after several
laughing fits entered the chamber and
removed pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case despite how
non-threatening pesterbot is there is
actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at
site-13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice
i am reborn to breathe devastation upon
this vetted earth pitiful humans you
will feel the dark sting of my
never-ending torment members of the task
force could see the original pesterbot
body on top of the larger metal
construct waving its arms madly the task
force opened fire to little effect
pesterbot tossed another piece of scrap
at them just narrowly missing one task
force member threw a frag grenade at the
robot which it caught blowing up its
hand another one was able to jump into
the air and reach the tiny robot atop
the larger body knocking it against the
wall and shattering it even in the
reality where pasterbot was able to
build itself a larger body it still
ultimately wasn't able to put up that
much of a fight poor pesterbot doomed to
be a failure in this and apparently
every other reality that's the story of
scp-1370
also known as pesterbot one of the most
hilariously harmless anomalous entities
that the foundation currently has in
containment perhaps one day he'll
achieve his goal of conquering the
universe he just has to figure out how
to conquer his toy box first now check
out
scp-001 the scarlet king and scp-999 the
tickle monster for more fascinating
beings from the scp foundation
[Music]